metro police are stepping up patrols to
curb crime in the far northeast valley
officers released an alert today asking
people to avoid what's known as the
saddle an open desert area off of lake
mead right near the edge of the valley
sasha loftus spoke with those who live
in that area about the crime issues
they've seen and what they think can be
done to stop them
brian this is the area police are
talking about here on lake mead past
hollywood this big open area right at
the eastern edge of the valley neighbors
say this crime issue is nothing new and
officers are hoping to change that
i didn't expect it to happen to me
murray cameron rosandes has dealt with
crime in the northeast valley first hand
it happens but then when i have to see
you you're like what how
she had her car stolen right from her
front yard last year and says she's made
it a point to stay safe since i feel
like any place you know during the day
it's one thing in the night time it's a
different animal andrew gutierrez also
lives in the area and says while these
issues are nothing new they're top of
mind
metro police say this desert patch known
as the saddle on lake mead at the base
of frenchman mountain is a big part of
the problem officers are seeing an
uptick in violent crimes there
statistics showing more robberies
burglaries and car thefts so far this
year so they're stepping up patrols to
try and get it all under control
presence is only
enforced when someone is there actually
doing the enforcing not just by passing
by and just oh there's a cop those in
the neighborhood welcome the extra
effort
but say no matter what it's especially
important to always keep an eye out for
each other stay safe take care of your
kids keep them close at all times
metro says shootings are also a big
problem and since a department shooting
range is nearby neighbors tell me it's
hard to hear where those sounds are
coming from police will also be working
with the blm and other agencies in this
effort